all right the man in charge of the  raiders will have big decisions to make  in the off-season here john gruden with  all of raider nation aren't satisfied  with an eight and eight season mark  but if you're a glass half full kind of  person well at least his first season in  vegas  wasn't a losing season this was a  one-game improvement over last year but  the defense let the nation down and  fixes need to be made and it starts  right away with gruden hiring a  defensive coordinator  sooner than later well we expect rod to  be a big part of this  defense moving forward i think he's as  good as there is really  on that side of the ball he's proven  that for a long time  and yes we'll begin our search tomorrow  we plan to move quickly and we're  excited about  this process look for an announcement on  a new defensive coordinator perhaps  within a week or so  the raiders and every other nfl team  hoping for fans in 2021  what a difference it could make here in  las vegas